you grew up in Los Angeles right Agoura
Hills a gory house okay like you you're
going up Malibu and you're just past it
and you go through the canyon so right
when you go out the canyon that's agora
agora okay but you live in New York now
so you went away to school Atlanta in
the UK and then you decided at some
point to pursue acting in your life in
New York what was behind that choice I
think I still wanted to see more of the
world before I went back to LA put a few
more notches under my belt
New York's just the city have always
wanted to live in I saw it in movies
growing up and such a romanticized City
and I just wanted to do more of my craft
there not that there's not craft in LA
but I really wanted to challenge myself
and and do some more plays as well as
maybe audition for films and because
they have film and TV in New York but
they have a lot of theater so I think
there's a lot of stuff that you would
not be able to do in Los Angeles I just
think it's a good way to get experience
and just get stripes what was the day
like when you made that decision I think
I want to go to New York that was
shortly after I finished school I think
it was when because I was an American
student and all graduating American
students whether you're on the
three-year course the two-year course of
the one-year course do an American
showcase in New York and in LA and when
I was in New York it was different and I
thought I think I want to try New York
just I like the hustle and bustle I was
like I'm just want to try it right and
there's maybe more of an upfront it's
more raw more upfront more yeah I think
so and maybe did you did you find that a
little bit exotic I mean having the LA's
you know pretty smiles and they you know
they don't want her anyone's feelings
but it seems like New York it's almost
better to know upfront how something is
yeah I don't know if I'm saying that
correctly I did yeah mm-hmm so was two
for you was that refreshing that it's
just more this is how it is and we're
not gonna sugarcoat it but then there's
no pretenses about yeah I like that in
New York to be fair a lot of people dish
when you're done with the audition they
want
even talk to you they'll just say you
know thanks thanks for having you you
know so but I think people there in
general are more upfront
I think people there are more devoted to
like auditioning a lot and taking
classes and not just wanting to be
famous because if you're in New York
you're not gonna get famous for very
long time if you get famous at all I
mean same thing in Los Angeles but I
feel like especially in New York yeah I
think you have to be there for a long
time before you start getting stuff
unless you're like a dynamite dynamite
actor hmm I'm not that good well why
don't you think you're there yet hmm
it's gonna do more okay you know just
gotta find myself and just be confident
in my body and Who I am
take some people longer than others you
know is that something you were self
aware of or did someone tell you that a
casting director kind of I just think it
at it lambda you know it cut me down a
notch because I not that I didn't know
it was good but I just realized that you
know like you're not gonna have people
raving about you right away you really
got to put in these hours and you really
got to find yourself because I kind of
felt like people didn't always
necessarily I don't know if they
necessarily got who I was as an actor or
what I was trying to do I mean I still
learned a lot don't get me wrong and I
had great teachers there and I made
great friends but I kind of felt like I
was like damn I don't know if I really
know my technique yet I know what I want
and know what I believe I still got to
figure out how I do what I do you know
so I just think that uh I don't know you
know some people it just takes a while
just kind of be comfortable and know
what they're doing
I think Sanford Meisner what's that it
takes 20 years to make an actor
you